here we are sitting here again opening
the show with a story that we've heard
too many times I I honest to God don't
know what it's going to take I don't
know what it's going to say reporting in
Nashville we do love you people will say
Nashville strong but we ask the question
why do you have to be strong because
we're beginning again this morning with
another horrific example of gun violence
in America and today that violence has
visited the city of Nashville a city now
in mourning after six people were killed
yesterday at the Covenant School which
teaches preschool we're talking kids as
young as three years of age through
sixth grade and three of those six
victims were children police have
identified the suspect as 28 year old
Audrey Hill Hale was shot and killed at
the scene according to law enforcement
Hale was a former Covenant student and
the motive of the of the attack is
unclear but police say they have
obtained a Manifesto there is
surveillance footage of the shooter
arriving at the school and a warning it
is very very disturbing it shows hell
firing through glass doors and entering
the building just after 10 o'clock
yesterday morning before entering the
Halls these are kind of images that we
see far too often these days young
school children
holding hands as they are evacuated from
the school that's supposed to be a safe
place every time I see these pictures
it's tough now these kids were reunited
with their parents they're the lucky
ones but here's the thing there's so
many families in this country who never
get that moment again with someone that
they love after school shooting you get
up you go to school you think it's going
to be another day and it is not there
have been more than three dozen mass
shootings this month alone not this year
this month and more than 130 this year
we of course have a team on the ground
in Nashville we'll start with our lead
National correspondent David bagno David
good morning
morning Gail behind me is the scene of
yesterday's tragedy the Covenant School
police said they first got that 9-1-1
call shortly after 10 A.M
suspected shooter was dead within 15
minutes but the damage was already done
six people including three children lost
their lives we don't yet know a motive
but we do know about the weapons
involved Nashville's police chief said
the suspect was carrying an
assault-style rifle an assault style
pistol and a handgun
law enforcement believes two of the
weapons were obtained legally
know about those victims here are their
names sixty-year-old head of school
Catherine Coos custodian Mike Hill
substitute teacher Cynthia Peak both 60s
61 years old and three nine-year-olds
Evelyn Dickhouse William Kenney and
Hallie Scruggs the daughter of Covenant
senior pastor on covenant's website
there's a welcome message from Coombs
who expressed covenant's Mission helping
children become who God intends them to
be yesterday's senseless violence robbed
three young children of that very genius
the silent surveillance footage shows
the shooter driving into the Covenant
school's parking lot in a Honda Fit
around 9 53 a.m you can see children on
a playground in the background nearly 20
minutes later the shooter fires through
glass doors on the side of the building
to gain entry concern back to Shooter
police say they received a call about an
active shooter at 10 13 a.m by that time
the surveillance video shows the shooter
was already in a hallway inside the
school five minutes after that opening a
door to an office and then re-emerging
moments later I was hoping this day
would never ever come here in the city
but we would never wait
to make entry and to go in and to stop a
threat especially when it deals with our
children authorities say the shooter's
victims were on the building's first
floor
and when police arrived the shooter was
firing at responding officers from a
window on the second floor these images
show where the bullets hit police car
windshields 14 minutes after receiving
that 9-1-1 call police say they killed
the shooter
in the immediate aftermath school buses
evacuated Covenant students to nearby
Woodmont Baptist Church
there they held hands as they got off
the bus single file
before reuniting with their families who
were so anxious to see them Ashby
Beasley was in Nashville on vacation but
she came to the scene in solidarity she
and her son survived a different mass
shooting in Highland Park Illinois just
last July how is this still happening
how are our children still dying and why
are we failing them expectedly
shock to this to this little
neighborhood
it's Green Hills
people here told us it's a close-knit
community which is known for being a
safe place I don't know how do you talk
to your three-year-old about why they
were in lockdown today Natalia Cooper's
children don't go to Covenant but she
was so emotional as she told us their
schools had been on lockdown just nearby
just happy to be reunited with them and
so sad for the families that were
affected it's heartbreaking
family's worst nightmare in Washington
President Biden responded to the
shooting by renewing his call for
Congress to pass an assault weapons ban
we have to do more to stop gun violence
it's ripping our communities apart
back here in Nashville police searched
the suspect's home Monday afternoon
the police chief says they found a
Manifesto tied to the shooter as well as
detailed maps of the school and a
mention of a potential second location
that the shooter later decided against
allegedly because there was too much
security at that location when we send
our kids to school or to any place of
safety we expect them to live learn have
fun and come back from that day's
experience we don't anticipate things
like this
you just heard the police Chiefs say we
don't anticipate things like this even
so CBS News has confirmed the Covenant
School underwent active shooter training
in January of last year plus trauma
medical training one year ago today